for years toss two nickels suffered from
chronic back pain he went through
surgery six times and his search for a
cure even powerful painkillers like
morphine didn't help via Nova no I had
an operation after operation but the
pain continued it got even worse I had
pretty much given up hope that they
could ever help get it under control
[Music]
that despair finally brought him to pain
physician Barbara Klein man she put
nickels on a new highly effective pain
medication that was developed from a
toxin produced by a sea snail
in patients like nickels small doses of
the substance are constantly released
directly into the spinal cord via a pump
implanted in the abdomen finding the
right dosage is challenging but a major
advantage over other pain medicines like
morphine is that patients don't grow
addicted the aunt is a scrapper hearts
of hidden file only absolutely you know
what's you know and of the development
of this compound is a real innovation in
pain therapy until now we relied only on
very powerful morphine derivatives the
new substance is a thousand times more
powerful than morphine a lot of pain
therapists have been waiting for
something like this talking about the
time
these rare images of the predator
species that produces the toxin were
made by researcher bada Mara Oliveira
from the University of Utah the cone
snail kills its prey almost instantly
with a kind of high-speed poison arrow
researchers like Hainish Tara are racing
to uncover other promising substances
from the depths of the sea
dirty Savoy above a Salinas father Thank
You Snicket's cone snails are predators
but they're slow so they can't chase
their prey and they can't just seize it
that's why they need a toxin that's very
powerful and that acts very quickly
nowadays we assume that only snails that
evolved especially effective poisons
were really successful that there was a
lot of selective pressure there dr.
Susan see each of the around 800 known
cone snail species produces its own
cocktail of toxins any of the compounds
could prove to be the next big
pioneering medication
biologists chemists and physicians are
now working together to explore one of
the Seas most precious resources